I'm an almost 30 year old man this is
what I look like this is what I sound
like as an almost 30 year old man this
is what happens when you let people
transition in adolescence before they've
had a chance to grow up before they had
a chance to even learn who they were not
just let but pressure pressure people to
transition at these ages young
vulnerable people who are already so
suggestible and I feel like everyone is
ignoring the pain because they are
afraid that it threatens their choices
in their narrative if you want to
transition
in your 20s you've had a chance to be a
man or a woman and this is what you want
to do
okay that's one thing I do take
accountability I did it
I did it in secret for my parents I take
accountability for all my choices but
what is the trans Community going to
take accountability for theirs
for leading me down this path this is
the face of an almost 30 year old man
this is the voice of an almost 30 year
old man